>> Laura, no!
>> Wait Laura, what are you doing?
>> I'm just trying to give you superpowers, like the Mutant Ninja Turtles.
>> No, that much mutation that fast is just going to kill me.
>> Wait well, I'll just do it slowly.
>> No, no, no. Even if you go slower, you won't
kill me. But, I'm not going to get psychic powers, or anything
like you read about in graphic novels. I mean, at best
I might be lactose tolerant or resistant to malaria and HIV.
>> Sounds pretty good to me.
>> But, but, you can't control where the mutation's happen when you do it,
I mean, there's a trade off. With malaria
it can cause anemia and kill you that way.
>> Maybe I'll just put the ooze down then.
>> Yeah, and I mean, mutations are already happening all the time
anyhow, replication errors, UV damage from the sun, and so much more.
>> God it sounds like dangerous business just existing.
>> Oh, it is. In this lesson, we're going to
learn all about how mutation and variation happen in the first
place and how they spread throughout the population over many generations.
>> Matt, Matt, this sounds like a
science fiction movie with mutations spreading through populations.
>> Well, it kind is except we're going to talk
about real mutation. Knowing what you know about the human genome,
the composition of coding and non-coding regions, tell me right now
if you think most mutations would be advantageous, detrimental, or neutral.